foreign
is an Atlanta hi Ben welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hey how are you doing better than I
deserve what's up
yes I just had a question about
um contributing to a 401k when you're
trying to pay off debt so I'm in a
position where I've got some debt that I
work on paying off and my employer match
is 50 of 401k uh contribution so I'm
curious if it's a good idea to continue
to contribute there and just use
whatever extra I have to pay the debts
or to stop contributing completely and
pay the debts off and then go full force
in a 401k I mean I think it's great that
they're offering you that sort of a
match and the good news is after you pay
off your debt it'll still be there for
you so if it were me the whole thing
about paying off the debt right is you
you need this intensity you need as much
money as you can get your hands on going
towards this debt how much debt you have
to pay off
uh just about a hundred thousand hundred
thousand so man you need every dollar so
instead of putting that money to your
401k pull that money back out have that
available to you to put towards this
debt and my guess is man you're going to
be what's your income
about 125 000. all right in two years
you'll be ready to go
yeah you're gonna live on nothing beans
and rice rice and beans so what we
figured out Ben is that what we're
suggesting you do is stopping your 401k
you're going to miss the match for two
years
that is mathematically incorrect advice
agreed
yeah it's weird as a matter of fact in
the financial world it's Blasphemous
right okay yeah and so people call us uh
Heretics all the time we should be
burned at the stake but what we've
discovered is the number one key to
becoming wealthy is to be debt free
because you get control of your most
powerful wealth building tool which is
your income now once we know that that's
the number one key then what's the
number one or number two key to becoming
debt free what we've discovered there is
it is not a math problem as much as it
is an emotional decision and this
incredible Focus
and what you give up in math on the
match you gain in speed on getting out
of debt because you are laser focused on
one thing light dispersed simply lights
a room focused it's called a laser and
you can do surgery with it and so that's
what we're doing we're completely laser
focusing for a short period of time and
even though it on the surface it appears
to be mathematically incorrect on the
whole over a 10 or a 20-year picture it
is more mathematically correct because
you will actually get your hundred
thousand dollar Mountain climbed and be
done with it and there's something else
to add to that when you when you make
the choice hey I'm going to stop my
contribution that also signals okay this
this is serious this is important your
mind is saying game all yes game all
because you know you don't want to miss
out on that over this you know five six
years you gotta pay a this debt and make
that contribution pause worth it yeah
half butt doing five things gets you
nowhere
all in on one thing I'll bust it
and that's what happens everybody tries
to half butt do about six things at once
I'm gonna put money in my kids college
I'm gonna put money in my retirement I'm
gonna put money extra on the house I'm
gonna go on a vacation I'm gonna use
credit card points I'm going to half
butt my life away and end up with no
freaking money and that's what most
Americans do